Kristopher you have always been a
filmmaker interested in testing new
boundaries in storytelling and style I'm
wondering did outerspace always seem to
you the ultimate frontier that you
wanted to explore one of my most
important set Ematic memories was the
first Star Wars came out 1977 and I've
never really lost that that great sense
of what the possibilities of movies were
based on sitting there watching that as
a kid when that film was so successful
they rereleased Kubrick's 2001 my dad
took me to see that on a huge screen in
London and that experience as well
it's just absolutely seared into my
brain it's kind of yeah you can really
use a movie to try and try and take
people on a very distant journey I mean
there were various technical challenges
obviously and those I enjoy and you just
sort of you know you put a great team of
people together had a great visual
effects supervisor a great special
effects supervisor a brilliant
production designer had worked with
before Nathan Crowley great director of
photography who I hadn't worked with
before
hoist about noise admire who I think did
some stunning work so I had a great team
to put together to figure out how do we
create these environments how do we put
the actors into the reality of that we
made the decision early on not to do any
green screens on the film so we wanted
to have you know these guys come to the
set be able to look out the windows and
see what was going to be out those
windows and us be able to kind of you
know grab pieces almost like a
documentary you know that the setscrew
sorry spoke no green-screen so he built
all the sets there in the studio we were
on the glacier in Ireland we were in
Calgary in a house that was built and
how many 500 acres of corn fields but
the size and scope and the things around
us never felt overbearing I had a bit of
a concern going into it wondering if
that was going to be overbearing and if
I was going to feel like I was receding
beneath all that but didn't at all on
the actual shooting of any scenes felt
very intimate very similar to shooting
an independent film took your time was
raw it was natural
there's nothing else going on that was
the the pure focus of of everybody and
the crew and you never felt the outside
you never felt the weight of you know
having you never had to choreograph a
scene you were doing with okay and the
cranes going to sweep over and after you
say your second line step up on your
mark and then go e you never had you got
it was all human connection so it was
very intimate and personal that way so
it didn't feel like a huge movie now
mind you were breaking it down day to
day over five months I only felt really
huge I came to see what you just saw on
the screen that's where the scope but
the day to day was was just you know one
swing an axe one two one one at a time
slowly chop the tree down it was a
wonderful thing to be able to trust you
know that you be able to show up and sit
in the chair that you were sitting in
and when you would look out you would
see what your character would be seeing
and I remember there is one day when we
were shooting this scene where the
endurance starts to spend in order to
achieve gravity and the image of Earth
that we were looking at would sort of
rotate in the frame just outside the
window and I got motion sickness looking
at it even though I was sitting there it
was a great gift too you know we think
we've all done tennis ball acting at
this point and there is a certain skill
in that but when you can just let
yourself relax trust your circumstances
and focus on the work it's it's a great
gift I mean I don't know that that's
that's that was just it we didn't have
to play pretend we really didn't yeah
she has a great story of Adam she was
actually told we don't do that what is
that I miss you I accidentally said the
word pretend on set and I was gently
sternly told by Chris that oh no no we
don't do that here
we got to behave basically and react and
active it to the circumstances that were
there again if you you know the ship
banked right gravity took you left you
didn't have to really play that you saw
the event horizon rise outside of the
windshield we saw basically what you're
seeing up here Jessica you've got
stories about the dust we were not
having to play like we had dust in our
eyes we did for me I actually I've never
done a large film like this most of my
films are independently financed and
very small and I'd always had the
concern with doing a large film that the
acting would be secondary relationships
would be secondary in favor of special
effects and explosions what was so
incredible about working on this so it
didn't feel at all different from a
movie that I'd be making like honor
dollars a day six day weeks it we were
there and the focus was purely on the
relationships and yes the world was huge
and epic and there was dust flying at us
and I got to drive through corn and do
all these really fun exciting things but
the heart of the film is about the bonds
of love and it was nice to never lose
sight of that in the scope of this world
better food though 100 dollar day film
yeah yeah I've done a lot of large-scale
films at this point or for several years
have been doing very large girl films a
lot of action big sets big effects all
this stuff and the thing I've really
learned is if you do too much of that in
a row you know day after day you get
very bored with it it's really fun to be
able to do both things it's really fun
to be able to to work you know just with
you know Matthew
sitting there watching his children grow
up too fast you know and just just
shooting his reactions and it's the only
thing we're doing to be able to do that
one day and then the next day just blow
something up I mean it
it's really funny it's just really fun
what tools did you feel were most
important in grounding the science of
this film because there is a great deal
of theoretical and quantum physics
there's a lot of science in the film but
I always try to make the audience
understand you know that there's
emotional clarity of things that you can
follow the story emotionally there's no
test on the film afterwards feel free to
be relieved at this point it really is
about just going through the experience
with the characters and if you can just
relax and enjoy that ride you'll get
everything out of you need to we had an
incredible science advisor in the film
Kip Thorne great astrophysicist who's an
executive producer and he made sure that
if people are interested to look at the
sides of the film it is based in reality
he was offering a lot of great
possibilities for what astrophysics
relativity these things can offer you
narrative Lee and I found them far more
mind-blowing than anything I could come
up with
so I embrace that fully but the way I
look at it it's secular you watch a
James Bond film and Bond has to defuse a
nuclear bomb you don't really have to
know how he's defusing a nuclear bomb
you just need to know it's going to blow
up if he doesn't do it to me that's a
guiding principle for the role of
science in the film it's the rule set of
the film it underlies it and I always
feel as an audience member that I can
tell even if I don't understand that
rule set I can sort of tell if it's
there or not or whether it's constantly
being cheated and we really wanted the
film to feel like we were being honest
with the science even though the
audience can't be expected to understand
it while they watch the film I read the
script I had questions
like what is going on in this man's mind
I spent I spent a good afternoon with
Kip Thorne to try and get my my brain
around the plausibility of the world we
were going into and then I must say
daily III my favorite part of this
entire process was daily questioning
Chris about what are the rules and
logistics of this geography what's
grabbing what does it mean what's
gravity did happening here what what
house time different here you know I
needed I was curious myself but I needed
to know is Cooper the pilot as the men
you know and with a crew to best
understand the world through gone into
and that test that Chris is talking
about that no one has to take I think I
could have passed it while we were
shooting but now I may have forgotten a
few things yeah
and I don't know if I could pass it
unless you're still giving DS which I
think that was back in the 70s early 80s
it would be harder to pass now but I
understood the plaza billion I am I'm
happy to say yes I did understand what
was coming out of my mouth the time but
it took a lot of it took a lot of it
took a lot of work and took a lot of
asking Kip and then daily working with
with Chris and asking him on back and
forth and back and forth trying to
understand the logistics I had a really
great phone call with Kip it lasted a
few hours and kind of like my character
came with a pulse like series of
questions for him and while he was
explaining all the questions about the
physics in the film I knew exactly what
he was talking about I was able to
follow it and I just thought oh great
great I know what I'm doing so we we
finished up the phone call as it turned
out we both played the trumpet in high
school so we added on that note
literally and we hung up the phone and I
just my husband said so what did he say
and I went and I had no idea we just
talked about it was already gone and I
just thought okay well the good news is
I feel it I feel like I understand it so
that's good but it led to this really
important part of my
character which was feelings matter it
wasn't just about the science and I
loved the idea of playing a skeptic and
a spiritualist you know she never gets
to do that and we live in a time where
we think of at least I encounter the
world is the way it's presented to me as
in binary forms we're very much
either/or and Stephen Sondheim has this
great line in a song which is must it
all be either less or more either plain
or grand as it always or is it never and
you're going to hear Emily Blunt sing
that line in a few weeks and and I
thought my character really got into
that into the end and so I loved getting
getting to explore the physics and then
also exploring what that would have
meant for her emotionally and
spiritually none of you got to write
equations on a board other than Jessica
and let's talk about your equation range
music
I mean KITT Kip was on set you know when
we were doing all of that those things
and I was bemoaning a bit and saying my
goodness how do you guys what exactly
does all this mean and you know it's
this is really difficult to memorize
because it was an actual equation it
wasn't just something that you know
Chris wrote said okay this will look
good Kip wrote it and he told me in
actuality the equation I was writing
with last three blackboards long at
which point I was very comfortable with
understanding that I would never be able
to know what Kip knows but I can act
like I know it hit those and that was
the best part for me I definitely felt
that I wanted the story to have a
certain symbolic quality with certain
symbols simple things the planets for
example one is water one his ice
one is desert at the end you know I
wanted things to have almost like an old
silent film like certain symbolic
relevance things like the dust things
like you know the way the characters
interact is a smaller number of
characters in this film and
I've made a very long time and the
interactions are actually even though I
think they're very layered and I think
what these guys have done is very real
and layered
they're actually quite simple as well in
an almost a fable like way and I really
tried to look back to the great silent
films for that Erich von Stroheim
degreed in particular I think one of
things I love about 2001 is it's almost
like a silent film something about even
though people talk a hell of a lot in
this film but something about those
simple visual symbols and the way the
symbol of the symbolism of the story is
relatively stripped down it felt like
that would help you understand the human
significance of the the more cosmic
elements of the film you could say that
I in one way that the science fiction is
is about what brand character brought up
about love being able to transcend that
time I mean we all know that our
intuitions are love or for people of
faith God direct our our lives but it's
not measurable we know it we know it has
import and it directs us but we don't
have a metric system to measure it so
therein lies a very intimate science
fiction film which i think is brought up
in this and it's not about going out
there it's actually that coming right
back in here which is an experience I
really enjoy with the film and the fact
that the further out there that we go
the more personal the film actually
becomes